if you announce Alex Pier Tom aspal 300
you did it Daddy and then if you went
also Conor McGregor Lon Edwards you want
your mind blown that would do it Connor
Leon Tommy Aspen Alex Bea Main Event
co-main Event mind blown would Conor do
a CO he wouldn't so you would do Conor
Leon Edwards Tommy Aspen and Alex Pier
wait so that would also make Connor a
triple champ so it's I'm losing all
energy
double triple chance you in the Co in
the Main Event co-main Event you have
two gentlemen and they're going to be
big underdogs but if they pull it off
you have the for the first time ever two
triple crown Champions y you havec 300
you think the three is just a
coincidence oh wow see where you're
going see where I'm going mhm see where
I'm going